[Musique]
ce qui manque vraiment aujourd'hui c'est
c'est le tourisme vraiment et du coup la
peau vraiment la commune ne profite pas
de cet endroit vivre vraiment
l'insécurité l'insécurité qui est là
[Musique]
l'histoire dit que le cafard du diado a
été
construit par les cultes
maintenant et en 3e position les
calories
vous avez bien que les gens ont toujours
passé ils ont toujours dit qu'il est
vraiment impératif il est nécessaire
d'écrire ça au patrimoine de l'Unesco et
la population vraiment on se retrouve à
travers ce format
ça fait partie de notre culture
et ça fait partie quand même de
toute notre histoire
[Musique]